ganz schön idyllisch hier am
Rhein
Ingelheim eine ganz normale deutsche
[Musik]
Kleinstadt aber hier irgendwo lebt die
reichste Familie Deutschlands
geschätztes Vermögen mindestens 50
Milliarden
Euro das ahnt man hier nun wirklich
nicht auf der Liste der reichsten
Deutschen taucht die Familie nicht auf
warum sage ich Ihnen später der Reichtum
der deutschen Milliardäre ist eher
unsichtbar und das obwohl er immer
größer
wird wir wollten wissen wie ist es so
unermesslich reich zu sein wie groß sind
Macht und
Einfluss und was sagen die Superreichen
dazu dass die Empörung immer größer wird
ein Jahr lang haben mein Team und ich
versucht in die Welt der Superreichen
hineinzukommen wir wollten nicht über
sie reden sondern mit ihnen ich habe ein
Milliardär im Privatjet begleitet ich
will in den nächsten 5 Jahren so und so
viel Cash hab und dann hatte ich 150
Millionen
Cash und ich habe erfahren dass man sich
wenn der Preis stimmt im Grunde alles
kaufen kann auch die Möglichkeit kaum
Steuern zu zahlen wir haben recherchiert
zu steuermodellen für Superreiche ein
anonymer Informant sagt uns da kann man
zum Teil auf maximal 1% Steuern
kommen wir haben uns die Tricks der
steuersparbranche angeschaut versteckt
gefilmt und waren Buff warum spricht in
diesem Kreis eine topbeamtin aus dem
Bundesfinanzministerium wir haben ja
Werkzeugkästen da können sie ihre
Mandanten beruhigen ernsthaft wir haben
über all das diskutiert wenn ich das
gewusst hätte hätten wir das Interview
nicht gemacht und wenn sie nicht so nett
wären würde ich es jetzt auch abbrechen
und dann lassen wir Schauspielerin Ester
Schweins für uns noch geheime Daten über
Deutschlands Milliardäre enthüllen na
[Musik]
neugierig wer sehen will was sich mit
Geld kaufen lässt beginnt am besten hier
Monaco
yachtshow superjachten gehören zu den
teuersten luxusb der Welt sie kosten bis
zu 500 Millionen Euro pro Boot dafür
sind sie komplette
Maßanfertigungen das heißt der Besitzer
bekommt alles was er will den eigenen
Heli an Deck den selbstpielenden
[Musik]
Flügel und an der Wand im Salon ein
Original alle Bilder an Bord sind von PI
aber sind keine Fälschungen sondern sind
echte
und in dieser versteckten Garage
verbirgt sich übrigens der neueste Trend
der Saison ein Mini U-Boot für private
Tauchgänge also ist wie so ein
Accessoire für das Boot eigentlich oder
richtig also bei uns fällt das unter die
unter dem Begriff Toys ist also eines
der
[Musik]
Spielzeuge in der yachtbranche merkt man
dass es immer mehr Menschen gibt für die
ein paar Millionen Peanuts sind über
1000 neue superjachten wurden in der
letzten Saison bestellt ein Viertel mehr
als im Jahr davor und sie werden länger
die deutsche Werft Abeking hat gerade
ein 118 m Boot
verkauft die Zahl der Superreichen in
Deutschland steigt ja auch merken sie
das ja wir hatten früher überhaupt keine
keine Kundschaft aus Deutschland jetzt
haben wir doch schon Anfragen aus
Deutschland und die Leute wollen auch
zeigen was sie erreicht haben im Leben
das ist sind nicht nur immer Leute die
das auch richtig für sich nutzen sondern
auch als Aushängeschild
nutzen Monaco ist wie eine Karikatur
großen Reichtums was man hier versteht
ist die dekadente Seite von Vermögen
mehr aber auch
nicht wie ist es wirklich so reich zu
sein dass man sich all das hier kaufen
kann das wollen wir wissen und Fragen
deutsche Milliardäre ob wir sie treffen
können SAP Gründer Hasso Plattner
Internet
dommut oder Hanspeter wild den Chef von
Caprisonne die alle drei übrigens auch
Jachten
besitzen und wir fragen viele andere
deutsche Superreiche aber keine Chance
wir bekommen nur
Absagen doch dann plötzlich werden wir
eingeladen Salzburg Flughafen Privatjet
Terminal der Hans-peter wild ist nach
langem Zögern bereit uns
mitzunehmen wir fliegen nach Paris zum
Profi Rugby Club stad Francis den sich
wild gekauft hat an Bord nicht nur Chefs
Jes monque sondern auch das trinktütchen
das ihn reich gemacht hat her werden sie
eigentlich gerne Mr cisan genannt ich
identifizere bin in der kon ein
weltweites sehr erfolgreiches Getränk V
dem in Amerika zumindest niemand weiß
dass es aus Deutschland STT trinkm rein
Caprisonne
raus die Caprisonne ist eine der
deutschen Wirtschaftswunder
Erfolgsgeschichten Hanspeter wild hat
die Firma von seinem Vater übernommen
und mit der genialen Idee für eine ganz
neue Verpackung zum Weltkonzern
gemacht sein werbekuh die Kampagne mit
Boxer Mohammad
[Musik]
Ali
haben Sie eigentlich sowas wie ein
Lebensmotto
hard es gibt kein Erfolg ohne hatte
Arbeit egal wo ich habe immer hat
gearbeitet und dann braucht der Mensch
der braucht auch etwas zum Loslassen und
das ist fun dazu gehört auch dieses
Flugzeug mit dem ich also bis vor covid
dreimal im Jahr um die Welt geflogen bin
viele Sachen kann man ja gar nicht
machen ohne ohne ein Flugzeug wie Diesel
ja Beweglichkeit und morgen da sein und
so
weiter für mich ist es der erste Flug
mit einem Privatjet und ganz ehrlich es
ist wahnsinnig bequem Landung in Paris
Bourget einem Flughafen den man nur mit
Privatflieger ansteuern darf die Wagen
stehen schon bereit ein paar Schritte
übers Rollfeld keine Kontrollen keine
Schlangen und nicht mal eine halbe
Stunde später sind sind wir schon in der
Pariser Innenstadt schneller geht's
nicht wenn Hans-peter wild in der Stadt
ist übernachtet er meist hier im
lebristol ein Hotel das übrigens der
deutschen milliardärsfamilie ög
[Musik]
gehört wild empfängt uns zum Interview
in seiner
[Musik]
Suite er bekommt hier einen Sonderpreis
regulär kostet die Suite an diesem
Wochenende 17000 € pro Nacht
und zwar man glaubt es kaum ohne
Frühstück das wird extra
berechnet wie ist es eigentlich mehr
Geld zu haben als man jemals wird
ausgeben können darüber habe ich schon
nie nachgedacht habe ich schon nie also
ich mein ist auf jeden Fall sehr gut
welches zu haben ja es gibt nämlich
autonomy Unabhängigkeit ich hatte nie
Cash weil das ganze Cash ja ins
Unternehmen geflossen sind und ich war
ganz konkret war ich im Hurricane Hugo
das war 89 in Puerto Rico und bin Gott
sei Dank im ersten Flugzeug da
rausgekommen habe gesagt mein Gott du
hast ja kein Cash ja und dann habe ich
reingeschrieben in meine objectives ich
will in den nächsten 5 Jahren so und so
viel Cash haben und dann hatte ich 150
Millionen Cash ja zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben wie war das für sie
und gut angefühlt ist das Bild was von
vermögenden in Deutschland existiert ist
das
fair ist ein negatives Bild würde ich
sagen ja mein Vater hat mir als noch
relativ jung war hat er mir gesagt das
größte Problem in deinem Leben was du
haben wirst ist die vielen Leute die auf
dich neidisch sind ist es gerecht dass
eine Person mehrere Milliarden besitzt
und andere so wenig besitzen ja auch die
Frage der
ganz akademische Frage
für mich stellt sich mir nicht kan auch
sagen 3 Milliarden warum hat jetzt der
besus so und so viel
Milliarden im Ranking der reichsten
Deutschen belegt Hans-peter wild Platz
77 mit 3,1 Milliarden Euro grob
geschätzt und zwar vom Manager Magazin
das jedes Jahr eine Liste der
Superreichen veröffentlicht aber Moment
da fehlen doch
Namen
z.B die Familie hinter dem
Pharmaunternehmen böhinger aus dem
beschaulichen Ingelheim unseren Daten
zufolge besitzt sie mindestens 50
Milliarden Euro das wäre Platz
1 wir fragen beim manager magazin nach
dort bestätigt man uns dass tatsächlich
auf der Liste einige der reichsten
Familien fehlen das liegt daran dass
diese Familien vor Jahren mit Anwälten
gegen die Liste vorgegangen sind deshalb
hat sich das managermazin verpflichtet
sie nicht zu
nennen
es gibt in Deutschland keine offizielle
vermögensstatistik man kann nicht
einfach nachlesen wer wie viel besitzt
aber dieses Jahr hat ein Team aus
Rechercheuren in Kleinstarbeit aus
verschiedensten Quellen alle verfügbaren
Informationen über Deutschlands
Milliardäre
zusammengesetzt ein riesiger Datensatz
der uns exklusiv vorliegt und der
überraschendes
enthält was genau zeigt ihn unsere
Vermögensverwalterin gib alles außer auf
gib alles außer auf ja gib alles außer
auf
oh ich sehe ich habe Besuch
ach sie wollen also einen Blick in den
geheimen Maschinenraum der
reichtumsvermehrung werfen ja na gut ich
habe Informationen bekommen die vorher
noch niemand bekommen hat man hat mir
Daten zugespielt einen ganz Kfer voller
Daten über Deutschlands
Milliardäre großartige
[Musik]
Daten also für mich denn es gibt noch
mehr extrem reiche in Deutschland als
bisher angenommen und sie sind noch
reicher und das
bedeutet noch mehr Kunden für
mich
ja sehen Sie mal hier ich habe hier
Namen von mehr
milliardärsvermögen in nur drei Ländern
der Erde gibt es mehr und Deutschlands
Milliardäre haben noch viel mehr Geld
als bisher vermutet und zwar
500 Milliarden Euro mehr damit könnte
man dieses Haus hier 500 000 Mal kaufen
oder ganz Berlin na also fast alle Wohn
und Geschäftshäuser oder sie geben
einfach möglichst viel von dem Geld an
mich als kleiner Annehmlichkeit denn ich
helfe ihn ja schließlich dabei dass ihr
Geld immer mehr
wird schaltet die Stellenanzeigen online
wir wir
[Musik]
wachsen Berlin
kurfürstendam ich bin mit einem Mann
verabredet dem zwar nicht die ganze
Stadt gehört aber doch
einiges nicht nur dieses Haus
und
dieses sondern auch dieses hier ganze
Straßenblöcke h begrüßen Sie das ist
also ihr Haus ja das ist das Haus was
wir als letztes groß siert hab geh rein
[Musik]
ja das Haus war mal ein Grand Hotel
thomas hat es für einen dreistelligen
Millionenbetrag renoviert wo heute die
Weinkühlschränke sind das war die das
waren die Aufzüge da sehen sie im Grunde
noch genau die Belichtung der
Aufzugsschächte sind wahrscheinlich auch
nicht die schlechtesten Tropfen hier
drin nein also das gehe ich mal von aus
was ist der teuerste Wein den sie haben
weiß ich gar nicht der Geschäftsführer
weiß was was ist der teuerste Wein im
Haus ein metto 2017 der kostet 2000 €
2000 € für eine Flasche eine Flasche
gönnen sie sich solche Weine auch nein
überhaupt nicht kein
[Musik]
Interesse
Thomas per kommt aus einer Familie die
seit Generationen reich ist sein
Großvater Robert Pferdmenges war Bankier
und Berater von Bundeskanzler Adenauer
der Familie gehörten Anteile der
Privatbank s Oppenheim in ihren besten
Zeiten die größte Europas auch per hat
eine Yacht eine
Segeljacht er war erfolgreicher
Rennfahrer und Chef der Edelmarke
Bugatti also was wir jetzt hier so sehen
und miterleben ist ja nur ein kleiner
Teil ihres Lebens sie sind Erbe sie sind
er eentlich ich kann nicht nur sagen das
Erbe ist da sonst ich hatte einen guten
Start ins Leben wenn man das das gar
keine Frage aber das ist nicht das was
ich im Leben verdient habe nicht mal
acho das habe ich alles selber verdient
woran machen Sie es denn fest dass sie
mit den Dingen die sie anpacken Erfolg
haben wenn ich was mache rechne ich mir
schon aus dass man scheitern kann jeder
kann scheitern ist do nicht so schlimm
aber letztendlich geh gleich mit
Restaurant das wird zum Erfolg hier
vorherören W ich
auch ja das wird hier zum
Erfolg und dann erfahren wir von Thomas
pcher noch wie man unter Superreichen
Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten löst eines
Tages nämlich beschwerte sich sein
Mieter
Gucci über das Gewerbe im Nachbarhaus
ein Bordell wo war das Bordell hier
direkt um die Ecke hieß Flamingo Bar
okay und dann haben sie das Haus gekauft
damit das Bordell rauskommt wirklich ja
sicher hier hier war das Bordell drin
und zwar bis
hintendurch großes Bordell großes
Bordell im Kölner Reichenviertel
Marienburg hat Thomas per zwei Häuser in
einem lebt er in dem anderen dieser
Villa ist nicht viel mehr als sein Büro
aus dem er sein Vermögen verwaltet wie
reich sind sie denn im Internet steht
1,4 Milliarden ja quatsch totaler Blitz
da steht dies sein der reichste Kölner
ja das bin ich vielleicht tatsächlich
aber es dürften ja schon wir haben ja
die Häuser in Berlin z.B gesehen mehrere
hundert Millionen sein das ist richtig
schon richtig
50% der deutschen also die ärmere Hälfte
besitzt was glauben Sie wie viel Prozent
des Gesamtvermögens das ist ich Ken dir
diese Statistiken 1,4% ja ja klar und
wenn die jetzt 20% kriegen was passiert
dann haben die 20% Konsum kurze Blase na
sie haben bisschen mehr Sicherheit im
Leben wenn die das entsprechend wenn die
das entsprechend entsprechend
tatsächlich in dieser Richtung benutzen
würden dann haben sie recht tun sie das
weiß ich nicht aber das klingt jetzt so
als würden die Leute mit dem Geld nicht
umgehen können ich sorge dafür dass
gewisse Sachen passieren wenn das Geld
verteilt wird wird es nicht investiert
wird ausgegeben das kann ja auch
investiert werden die Leute können nur
nicht hab sagen Sie mir mal wer das ist
die Deutschen sind kein Land der
Eigenverantwortung in einem Punkt waren
sich die Superreichen einig
grundsätzlich ist es in Ordnung dass sie
so viel mehr haben als andere weil sie
sich ihr Vermögen erarbeitet was
aufgebaut haben und weil sie im
hochsteuerland Deutschland viel
abgeben aber gilt das denn für
[Musik]
alle herzlichen glückwunsch Sie haben
sich im Bewerbungsverfahren gegen
Dutzende andere durchgesetzt das heißt
sie haben bis gezeigt sie sind die
Special Force der
[Musik]
Superreichen ganz normal zu arbeiten ist
aus steuerlicher Sicht
suboptimal was war denn vorher ihr Job
erbefachfrau
Angestellter schön blöd haben sie ja
ordentlich viel Steuern bezahlt was
48% das ist das was Normalos wie sie als
Singles laut Netzwerk für
Steuergerechtigkeit an Steuern und
Sozialabgaben so abtreten die haben aber
auch ausgerechnet wie viel Steuern für
ein mustermillionär so
anfallen
24% also nur noch die Hälfte und das
alles ohne Tricks überhaupt ist die
Politik in den letzten Jahren den
Superreichen sagen wir mal
entgegengekommen nehmen wir z.B sie hier
Frau Susanne Klatten Unternehmerin BMW
Erbin geschätztes Vermögen mindestens 25
Milliarden Euro und gehen wir mal zurück
auf das Jahr
1996 da hörten wir im Radio die Fujis in
endloss Schleife im Kino lief Werner das
muss kesseln und er hier
war immer noch ewigkanzler Helmut
Kohl damals so steht es in den Daten die
mir zugespielt wurden wären auf die BMW
Erträge von Susanne Klatten satte
61% steuernfällig
gewesen aber seit damals kannten die
Steuern nur noch eine Bewegung
runter was für ein Glück keine
Vermögenssteuer
[Musik]
mehr Steuer
und runter mit dem
[Musik]
Spitzensteuersatz zurück in Paris beim
Rugby Club ST Fran der Verein den sich
cprisonnechef Hanspeter wild gekauft hat
er ist hier Monsieur le prident
investiert viele
Millionen vor dem heutigen Spiel soll er
die Entwürfe des Designteams für die ne
absen wild gefällt der Farbton nicht der
Geschäftsführer entschuldigt das sei
wegen des
[Musik]
druckersagt nach meiner
Meinung mitentscheiden sagt der
Geschäftsführer ich
sag immerhin sein Team enttäuscht ihn an
diesem Abend nicht und
[Applaus]
gewinnt
Hans-peter wild hat Deutschland vor
Jahren verlassen er ist in die Schweiz
gezogen in den Kanton Zug bekannt für
niedrige Steuern er erzählt mir dass er
damals nach seiner Scheidung einen neuen
Lebensmittelpunkt gesucht habe was sagen
sie den die finden das dass sie
vielleicht wegen der Steuer Deutschland
verlassen haben und dass das doch nicht
solidarisch gegenüber Deutschland ist
ich mich ja nicht rechtfertigen also wir
haben eine große Wahl die wir immer
machen können mit unseren Füßen
dahin gehen wo es uns
gefällt aus unseren Daten wissen wir
mehr als jeder zehnte der deutschen
Milliardäre hat bisher mit den Füßen
gegen die Steuergesetze abgestimmt und
das Land
[Musik]
verlassen und in der Politik weiß man
gehen noch mehr Superreiche sinken die
Steuereinnahmen kein schlechtes
Druckmittel für die die noch da
sind whalb all das möglich ist was wir
über Monate recherchiert
haben aber der Reihe nach beginnen wir
hier der China Club ein exklusiver
Privatclub eine Art Vereinsheim für
vermögende Kameras sind eigentlich tabu
aber wir dürfen hinein als Begleitung
von reiner zetelmann Multimillionär und
Stammgast hier das ist normalerweise
mein zweites Z Hause wo ich immer bin
das ist mein Lieblingsraum wie oft waren
sie schon hier im Chin Club
ca 3000 mal 3000
Mal bis zum Regierungsviertel sind es
nur ein paar Meter das macht den China
Club so attraktiv für die Elite aus
Politik und Wirtschaft wie es immer
wieder heißt die sich den Rückzugsort
einiges kosten lässt 10000 €
Aufnahmegebühr dazu 2500 €
Jahresbeitrag Kosten für Speisen und
Getränke können Sie ein Karottensaft
bitte bringen und ein Kamilletee alles
am Tisch eigentlich dann zeagen sie wo
der Karottensaft ist ich sehe keinen
sehen Sie den nee da haben sie
tatsächlich recht man muss schon ganz
schön vermögend sein um hier immer
wieder herzukommen
oder ja also sagen wir mal mit
Bürgergeld wahrscheinlich nicht zu
finanzieren oder bestimmt nicht zu
finanziieren
ja vor unserem Treffen hatte reiner
zietelmann uns ein Video geschickt
[Applaus]
es zeigt ihn auf seiner weltturnee
titelmann ist nicht nur selber reich
sondern forscht und schreibt auch über
andere Superreiche seine Bücher
erscheinen in 30 Ländern in Kursen gibt
er außerdem Tipps fürs reich werden so
mache ich Schluss mit der
durchschnittsexistenz sie schreiben
reiche sein eine diskriminierte
Minderheit das hat mich ehrlich gesagt
sehr überrascht wie kommen Sie darauf
ich habe geschrieben es ist eine
Minderheit die mit Vorurteilen und
Stereotypen konfrontiert ist ja weniger
so im täglichen erleben sondern in den
in den Medien ja oder auch in der
Politik dass das immer irgendwie eine
Stimmung gemacht wird gegen reiche ja
ich sag ihn jetzt in meinem Bekannten
Kreis sind überwiegend Unternehmer und
ich kenne fast keinen fast keinen der
nicht über auswandern nachdenkt und zwar
ernsthaft nachdenkt das werden jetzt
viele nicht tun aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen und warum denken die über
auswandern nach wegen dieser Stimmung ja
wegen dieser Stimmung weil sie sagen ich
fühle mich nicht willkommen ich fühle
mich nicht gewährtschätzt sie laden ja
zu Seminaren ein in denen vermögenden
Tipps gegeben werden wie sie ihr
Vermögen steuerschonend anlegen können
z.B in Stiftungen in liichtenstein warum
machen sie das warum geben sie diese
Seminare na was es da für eine Nachfrage
gibt das ist wie mit dem Hase und dem
Igel es gibt hier einen Kampf zwischen
der Staat und der Politik auf der einen
Seite und den Vermögen auf auf der
anderen Seite ja wo die einen der Staat
versucht immer mehr wegzunehmen und die
anderen versuchen auf logischerweise
irgendwie Mittel und Wege zu finden und
ich spreche jetzt nur von legalen wegen
um das zu verhindern und sie wollen den
Vermögenden da
helfen ich will mir erstmal selbst
helfen indem ich so Veranstaltung mache
und auch damit Geld
verdiene super reichen sagen wie sie auf
ihr vieles Geld weniger Steuern zahlen
müssen ein lukratives Geschäftsmodell
nicht nur für
Tiel wir hören es gibt eine ganze
Branche die sich genau darauf
spezialisiert
hat Frankfurt Bankenviertel wir sind
hier für einen ganz besonderen
[Musik]
Termin ich treffe jetzt gleich einen
Mann der sehr sehr lange überlegt hat ob
er uns ein Interview gibt er ist
Steuerberater aber kein normaler
Steuerberater sondern Steuerberater für
Superreiche unser Informant ist einer
der iertesten experten seiner Branche
einer äußerst verschlossenen Branche wer
mit Journalisten spricht riskiert seinen
Ruf hallo schön sie zu
sehen auch er hilft vermögenden die
Steuern zu senken zu gestalten wie es
heißt im Rahmen des Gesetzes das ist ihm
wichtig andere aber sagt er würden viel
aggressiver Vorgehen zum Schaden
aller wenn ihr weiterschauen wollt die
ganze Geschichte findet ihr in der ZDF
Mediathek
[Gelächter]
[Musik]